we started shotgun help our friends but
that quickly grew
into a full-blown mission for the whole
industry and so it's an enormous
honor to be recognized by the academy
for making a difference
the shotgun was definitely a
co-production with literally
thousands of people who helped along the
way
so we're going to read the names of all
3 420 people right now
okay at a high level
there's three generations of shotgunners
that we would like to thank
the early startup cast of crazies
to the second generation who helped us
scale the technology
and mind-blowing service and support to
the crew that's continuing to innovate
today
for the studios that rely on shotgun
every day
we'd also like to thank the hundreds of
productions who invited us in to work
with them side by side you were all so
incredibly generous
and we had a total blast working with
you
and finally we'd like to thank that wild
crew
in toronto that sparked this entire
thing our many mentors
and our families who went all in with us
you all rock
thank you we'd like to dedicate this
award
to all the filmmakers out there who
brought us all so many moments of joy
and wonder
in a year when we desperately needed it
you are our heroes
thank you
you